So we have some big news from the Corona virus
testing vaccine front.
There are a ton of Corona virus vaccines in
development.
We've talked about some of them.
Some are sort of closer to a finished vaccine
than others.
And one of the prominent vaccines is the Oxford
Kovik 19 vaccine.
We talked last week, maybe it was the week
before about the Madona vaccine.
Another one of the more advanced vaccines
is the Oxford vaccine.
And this month, they are going to be moving
into phase two and three trials, which will
encompass a total of about 40000 people.
So 40000 people, 40000 volunteers are about
to receive the Oxford Corona virus vaccine,
which is huge.
It's going to provide very important information
about the effectiveness of the vaccine at
preventing corona virus.
So just to remind you sort of the process,
safety trials were done before phase one.
The question is, does the human body tolerate
this?
Aside from whether it will make you immune,
does the body tolerate this safely?
Are there side effects, et cetera?
We got past that with the Oxford vaccine.
Then we had a phase one trial.
Phase one trial is a relatively small group.
It was done in April.
1000 people were immunized.
A follow up is happening now.
So far, phase one has determined that the
vaccine is causing the body to generate antibodies.
That's very good.
So this next part is going to add about 10000
people in a phase to trial, which will expand
the ages that those first thousand were all
adults, but not older adults.
So we're going to fight.
We're going to now in phase to see 10000 people,
which will include some older adults and some
kids receive the vaccine.
The point of phase two is, does the age of
the person affect antibody generation?
Do older adults generate the same antibodies
as younger adults?
Do children generate the same antibodies with
this vaccine as younger adults?
Then there will, I believe, simultaneously
be a phase three trial going on, which is
going to, again, just focus on a narrower
age range of adults.
But it will be a test for efficacy with an
additional 30000 individuals at least.
And then the question is, again, we're going
to go from a thousand people to 30000 and
see how many of them are generating antibodies
after receiving this vaccine.
That phase three will also include a control
group, which is a very important thing.
So the phase two three trials combined will
include over 40000 people.
We're going to get very valuable data from
this.
And it does take some time with the early
trials.
We've seen that it can take upwards of 40
days for the body to get to its full antibody
generation after receiving the vaccination.
So once you have the antibodies, which can
take 40 days, 43 days in one study, then you
need to follow all of those people and see.
We'll do do they get coronavirus?
Does this actually work to protect them from
corona virus?
And of course, how long does it provide immunity?
You could you could say after three months.
Well, it seems like this vaccine is providing
at least three months of immunity.
But you need six months of following those
people to be able to say, well, it looks like
it provides six months of immunity.
And that's something that if there's an early
enough efficacy signal.
So imagine that by October, they say, well,
it seems to provide at least five months of
immunity.
You could potentially get an emergency use
authorization and say, hey, if it provides
five months of immunity and it's safe, let's
start giving it to health care workers.
Five months is better than nothing.
Now, could this be sped up at all?
I've mentioned challenge trials in the past.
Typically, challenge trials are not done with
a vaccine like this.
A challenge trial would be rather than doing
phase three, where you just follow people
and see if they get infected at a lower rate
than those in the general population.
You can deliberately expose people to the
virus.
That's what a challenge trial would be called.
That could potentially shorten phase three
and more quickly demonstrate that it generates
antibodies that provide protection.
It wouldn't tell you how long they last.
Maybe they last a year.
But you need a year to go by to know that
there is a debate about whether a challenge
trials should be done now outside of this
vaccine.
If you were interested in participating in
a challenge trial around Corona virus, there
are lots of different kinds going on.
Not necessarily for this vaccine.
You can find out about that at one day sooner,
dawg.
That's the number one.
A sooner or one day sooner.
Dot org.
The other question, when we're developing
a new vaccine and trying to figure out if
it works is manufacturing capacity.
So I've talked about this before.
If you wait to start manufacturing huge amounts
of the vaccine until you have results from
a Phase two three trial, it's too late in
the sense that it will take months with the
flu vaccine that starts to be available.
Don't hold me to this, but I think the flu
vaccine in in the U.S. starts to be available
like August, September.
Typically, they start manufacturing that.
I believe it's April, roughly six months before.
Five months before.
So what is happening here is that Oxford is
partnering with AstraZeneca.
They are now going to start manufacturing
large doses of this vaccine so that if it
does work well, there will potentially be,
you know, a hundred million doses total by
the end of the year from that batch.
Thirty million would be for the UK.
This is the Oxford vaccine and 80 million
would be for the rest of the world.
So cautious optimism is the right approach
right now.
This is one of the many vaccines that we've
talked about.
Last week.
We talked about Maduna.
We hope to have at least a couple of these
both work and be manufactured in bulk in advance
so that by the end of the year we could at
least hopefully dose several million Americans
with it.
And if you sit, I don't know what's going
to happen.
Of course, if you said, David, you've got
a bet, what would you bet is going to happen
with the vaccine?
My bet would be by the end of the year, there
will be millions of Americans vaccinated.
Now we're a country of 330 million people.
So if three million people are vaccinated
by December 31, it's both no huge win and
it's also not that unlikely.
But that's where I would put my money right
now.
I believe the U.S. will be in the millions
of vaccinations by the end of the year, but
it's going to take longer to really start
to approach what could even remotely be referred
to as herd immunity, which for something at
the contagion level of corona virus, is estimated
at about 70 percent immunity.